hello everyone and yes I know this is
the third video I'm making today I'm
basically ruining your Sunday but I
can't help it you know things are
happening in the chess world and that is
a good thing so here we have Fabiano
Caruana versus the unnie Pony she in day
two of the rapid really a crazy game I'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it so let's get
straight into it we don't have one nice
photo nothing crazy this time just you
know a nice photo of all the players
courtesy of Leonard totus official
photographer of the Grantchester there
we have it all the players before this
round you can see Nepos still enjoying
his happy bun and well everything else
seems perfectly normal now let's enjoy
the game so in the quran opens with
efore sorry about that and we have a
very nice opening we haven't had in a
long time d6 the pierce defense with d4
Knight to f6 and now Knight to c3 in
defending the pawn with g6 preparing to
fin care of the dark square Bishop
Bishop to e3 and now I just think
arrowing Bishop g7 Queen to be -
preparing the Castle queenside also
Bishop h6 is a popular idea with a six
by Napo and this is a not played all
that much here c6 is the main idea but
here a six nipple obviously prepared
something as he decided to play the
first against efore with Bishop to h6
going for this trade with castles Queen
side castles by Fabi and now b5 neppo is
ready to start an attack on the Queen
side as we have castles of opposite
sides and now there is one game where f3
was played but here Bishop captures on
g7 is a new move but not really as we're
gonna transpose into some of the games
that have already been played but
through a different move order King
capture some g7 with f3 now Knight to c6
and here
h4 now ready to push g4 h 5 h 4 and so
on the way of course you want to play
when you face the pigs defense and here
h5 is unknown move in this position but
nipple plays a five and it is as of move
tenders we have a completely new game so
let's see what happens
Fabi continues developing with Knight G
- and now B for kicking away the night
with Knight to d5 and now nepo doesn't
want to face any h5 ideas so he pushes
h5 himself we have night capture Sun
before night capture some d4 now Knight
captures on d4 pawn captures and now of
course you cannot recapture with the
Queen if you capture with the Queen then
c5 just wins the material here with we
have Knight to c6 with a double attack
Queen and the pawn and you are going to
recapture the d4 pawn with the night we
have Queen to e8 preparing to infiltrate
with Queen to a4 with nice capture Sundy
for now Queen to a4 hoping to capture on
e2 so King to be won by Fabi and now c5
so feel free to pause the video here and
what do you play here I'll just do a
couple of seconds I I know you all know
where this is going but I'm still gonna
you know give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player of knights on deadly squares and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
Knight to f5 is the move here Fabi
didn't play Knight a5 v to play Knight
to e2 he decided to go back with the
knife but Knight to f5 is deadly yeah
because you have to capture the night
you can't really allow Queen h6 after
the King moves so capturing with the
pawn isn't really even a sacrifice you
just go Queen g5 checking has the movie
pick up the night and you have a nice
open black King you know ready to be
taken down so after Knight a5 check
you're gonna have to capture with the
bishop it's the only idea and then after
he captures an f5 again what do you do
here now you are under heavy fire you
have to trade Queens but it's not enough
even Queen captures pawn captures you're
gonna capture on g6 after captures here
rook captures on b6 and after you count
everything White has six points black
has only four and this a sex pawn is
already under under fire so a5 but still
you're down two pawns you're gonna lose
this game it's a bishop against tonight
I would play on both sides of the board
so Knight a5 deadly but Fabi goes nights
- E - okay it's a rapid game you don't
want to over calculate anything we have
Ruby 8 by nipple of course you want to
put your rook on an open B file and
be three just defending with Bishop to
e6 now preparing c4 and now Queen to c3
nipple continues attacking we have c4
and now Knight to f4 now hoping to get
rid of this annoying Bishop here and
here if you play seek after son b3 you
don't achieve anything just yet because
the white just captures with chick
capture C capture son b3 and you're not
breaking through with blacks so after
night afore we have rook F the c8 first
now getting the other look into the
attack as well and now rook the d4 by
Fabi saying that okay if you capture
your queen will hang but never says no
problem he plays C captures on b3 so
what do you play
first Fabi plays Knight captures on e6
again and gets rid of one of the
attackers with check F captures on e6
and now eight captures on b3 Fabi says
I'm done with trading Queens if we if
you capture here I'm still up upon and
you it's very unlikely that you will
keep your AC exponent so I will very
soon be up two points in a similar
position to the one that we discussed
and white would be winning here so neppo
cannot afford a queen trade he has to go
back Queen to EA displayed and now Queen
to d2 going after the d6 pawn but also
preparing a queen to g5 and an attack on
the Kings side nepo continues attacking
a5 and now while you can capture here
first Fabi plays Bishop to a6 it
develops a piece with tempo and only
then will you recapture on d6 not
recapture capture we have looked the c6
and now rook captures on b6 rogue beat
the b6 defending rook captures Queen
captures and now Bishop back to e 2 as
your Bishop is under attack and the
neppo continues attacking we have a for
Fabi pushes B for the Queen now guards
the B to the B for pawn and the Queen to
c5 of course you cannot capture the pawn
is pinned but there is now a double
attack against the b4 pawn Fabi defends
it with c3 and now comes Queen to f2
going after that G to pawn you have to
grab some points back even though it
means opening up some files in front of
your King but you can't just wait for
for the game to you know go forward
without you actually
doing something so rook to d1 by Fabi
and here
Knepper just captures it rook captures
and g1 and now that the G file is ready
for attack Queen to e3 attacking the
rook on d6 but also guarding g1 so rook
to g1 is the idea Knepper moves the roof
we have looked to b7 and here we have
looked the g1 also possible was b5 a
very nice idea the bishop guards it
there and then you start pushing the C
pawn for example but ok who wouldn't
play Ruby g1 it's a very nice move we
have Queen to h2 and now you definitely
want to play b5 here just b5 the bishop
nicely defenses you're gonna push c4
next and then depending on what black
plays as the Queen is a bit you know not
doing all that much here on the Kings
side you may even be able to start
pushing on the Queen side but here Fabi
played Queen to g5 he wants the capture
on g7 with check but this this allows
neppo a very nice defense so again feel
free to pause the video here and try to
defend the g6 pawn how do you do it for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are again an
excellent player of knights well we
could say undead least-squares also and
if you just want to enjoy a show
Knight g4 is the move this is what
Knepper played we do we also have to see
what happens if you just capture the
bishop then black is getting checkmated
that goes without saying for example
King f8 you grab the night and now if
rook f7 you will just you know deliver
may 28th is mate and if you move the
King EA for example just captures here
King runs away you're gonna go check
here 27 and then rook delivers mate the
Queen controls all the squares here so
Knight g4 is the deadly line now you
cannot capture as your look is no longer
defended so capturing is out of the
question first if I we went to rook to
e1 and now Quinta f2 again nipple goes
after the rook so we have Queen to d2
you can't move the rook you have to
guard the bishop and now Knight to e5 we
have looked f1 by Fabi and now Queen
captures on h4 so never grabbing those
pawns very nicely with f4 attacking the
knight and now rook to d7 first
attacking fabi's Queen
we have queens that you want and now
Queen captures on e 1 we have rook
captures anyone and mountain I'd back to
f7 so after all of this craziness we
have this endgame where the material on
the board is equal if I be has a bishop
and a neighbor has a knight so let's see
what happens here and also nepo has four
point islands Bobby has two so why to
definitely has the advantage here with
King c2 not allowing this rook you know
go down we have E 5 now and F 5 of
course trying to create a weakness here
you don't want these two points
connected so we have h4f captors and g6
King captures and now b5 Fabi starts
pushing on the Queen side with King to
g5 and now c4 so those are two deadly
passed pawns with h3 by Neto that's also
very nice pass pawn and c5 now we have
King to f4 and now if Bobby played b6
here the correct move is c6 because
after b6 the knight can block all of the
light squares with Knight to d8 c6 is
much better because after Luke to c7
then you play rook F 1 check King has to
move and now you go Bishop to c4
threatened the night here and after 96
attacking the bishop kink the c3 and now
you want to go up King here King here
King here and the rook will do a nice
job guarding the back rank but Bobby
played b6 first and now we have Knights
to d8 here net was night to just
controls all of these squares and you
can't continue pushing your passports
which is well something you definitely
want to do we have Bishop to b5
attacking the rook and now rook the d4
is best here never win the rook to h7
and again Bobby misses the correct
continuation he plays c6 but he's very
long time there's no time to calculate
Bishop captures on a4 is the correct
idea because now after h2 you get rook
h1 defending and now after the King goes
after the rook King g3 now not c6 it
seems like c6 is winning but it's not
and it's really funny why not because
after c6 you get Knight captures Bishop
captures and rook h6 the point is that
the bishop and the King are on the same
file so if you move the bishop you lose
the b6 pawn here and if you start
pushing it
then you capture with check after King
knows you're gonna go here and you are
in time to prevent the pond from
queening and black wins the game
so after this King to g2 remove first
and nice in between move King D 3 now
the King and Bishop will no longer be in
the same file c6 is the idea and now
black will have to go back rugby 7
you cannot allow see now if c6 you will
be able to capture on B 6 and then Kings
before you're gonna go up the board here
here you can put the pawns and well it's
just gonna be a much better position for
white so like we said here rook to h7
Fabi didn't go for that he played c6
we're better of captures an a4 was
correct and now he allows neppo this
trade with Knight captures on c6 Bishop
captures and rope to h6 so here saying
either I will capture bishop and stop
the pawn or you move the bishop and I
win the pawn and again a bishop captures
on a4 is the way to go for Fabi but Fabi
plays Bishop to d7 probably with the
idea that if rook captures Bobby wants
to capture on h3 but nepo says nope not
happening h2 and now the thread is h1
queen with b7 far he also wants the
Queen his be pawn but once again and for
the last time I feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only winning
move for black in this position well
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
winner of end games and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
look the b6 you have to prevent this
pond from queening and once this pond
reaches a 2 white will have a hard time
dealing with both of these far advanced
fast bones which are very fast bones but
okay Bishop c8 defending the pawn and
now
a3 the King is unable to approach the a
pawn as the row covers the B file with
King to c3 and now King to g3 the king
wants to come to g2 to help out with the
promotion of the pawn with rook to a 1
hoping to win the pawn here but now a 2
and now of course you cannot capture it
because this pawn Queens with Bushra
back to e6 rook captures on b7 and now
again rook Bishop to b3 creating a
square for the King if you capture here
just Roque seven wins there's no way to
guard everything you will just either
capture here and then Queen the pawn or
you will just wait and wait for King g2
and the queening of the point so we have
Bishop to b3 and now comes a rook to e7
just defending the pawn here we already
mentioned that you cannot capture King
the c-4 by Fabi we have looked h7 now
again preparing to push to h1 but
there's no way around it Kings / Fabi
with h1 Queen rook captures on h1 rook
captures and Bishop captures on a - with
King to f4 and now Bishop to d5
defending the pawn here we have rook to
e1 and it was in this position on move
63 that Fabiana caruana resigned the
game if we're playing chess you should
at least resign and move 64 you know
just just for fun but okay he resigned
the move 63 with some I believe 12
seconds on the clock if you're wondering
how do you win this as it's unlikely
that you can win the point since the
bishop is guarding it you don't have to
once white makes a move you will just
grab the pawn and that's it if if he
moves the bishop you're just gonna move
the rook and push her passed pawn to
victory if Bishop captures this is a
winning endgame and then easy one you
just go all the way down with the King
King c3 now you push the pawn whatever
white place doesn't really matter you're
just gonna move the King check King
moves and then you get a queen into the
game and of course now you win so of
course Fabi knows this and after this
rook to e1 unmoved 63 he resigned the
game so once again sorry for a lot of
videos I know it's a Sunday and you have
a lot to do so a really sorry about that
but I thought you'd enjoy this one so
there we have it I would like to thank
David Gill for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of a lot of
things that are happening in the world
as really a lot is happening
continuing the Capablanca saga hopefully
very soon and checking up on your
suggestions thank you all I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your
Sunday
what's the left of it